we got robbed a lot when I was a kid I
would wake up with people downstairs and
you just know you're getting robbed and
it's a up feeling I walked in on
a few robberies you know I'm like nine
what are you gonna do yeah it's this big
guy with a TV and I'm like can I help
you and he's like oh I'm looking for
your dad and I was like oh let me go get
him and then he would just run out their
backyard with a TV what about New York
I've been robbed in New York the guy
went through my window in my apartment
up the fire escape opened my window
walked on my bed on your bed yeah cause
my bed was in front of the window didn't
wake you up no I wasn't home oh okay
okay yeah crazy story my girl was living
with me at the time she came home and
she opened the door and it hit a coffee
table and she's like hey why'd you put
the coffee table in front of the door
and I'm like get the out of there I
knew exactly what was going on and I'm
such an idiot that I had one drawer with
like six grand in it fireworks brass
knuckles all this dumb all of my most
prized possessions 18 year old boy he
just scooped all the cash and left then
they caught the guy they took one
fingerprint and they caught him like six
months later